helicópteros sobrevuelan kabul en
cercanías de la embajada de eeuu con el
rápido avance del talibán países como
eeuu reino unido alemania francia españa
italia suecia o canadá han acelerado la
evacuación de su personal
washington defendió el retiro de las
tropas de afganistán y culpó al gobierno
de kabul por el rápido deterioro de la
situación
la comunidad internacional invirtió en
20 años miles de millones de dólares en
las fuerzas 300.000 de ellas con una
fuerza aérea moderna y sofisticada algo
que el talibán no tenía act es
afortunada y trágicamente los afganos no
fueron capaces de defender el país y
creo que eso explica por qué la
situación se ha movido tan regis
guardeses porque spaces wood
mientras la otan reclamó de manera
urgente una solución política la
activista malayos upside que sobrevivió
un disparo en la cabeza de un talibán en
2012 expresó su preocupación por los
derechos humanos y pidió un cese al
fuego llamado pacífico al que se sumó el
papá francisco
piquetes y pegar el mail del apache les
pido que recen conmigo al dios de la paz
para que este es el estruendo de las
armas y se encuentren soluciones en
torno a una mesa de diálogo se destraba
t al cabo los del diálogo
pero esos pedidos parecen lejos de
convertirse en una realidad y muchos
afganos buscan escapar de cualquier
manera a países vecinos en pakistán se
observan largas filas en el cruce
fronterizo quienes vx tan han comenzado
a llegar refugiados afganos
otro posible destinos turquía donde se
teme una aliada de emigrantes por eso el
presidente de recep tayyip erdogán llamó
a apoyar los esfuerzos de paz y
estabilidad en afganistán para evitar
los desplazamientos masivos